eine unterirdische anlage die vom
schrecken des kalten krieges kündet um
eine idee von den immensen ausmaßen
dieses orts zu bekommen muss man
darunter das haut einen um
ein modernes bauwerk das bei einem
attentat während des zweiten weltkriegs
eine wichtige rolle spielte es passiert
nicht oft dass man traurig darüber ist
dass sein tod verhindert wurde so wie in
diesem fall
eine gottverlassene landschaft mit einer
geheimnisvollen geschichte
bei den grabungen fand man leichen die
ganz offensichtlich ermordet wurden
und ruinen auf einer karibikinsel die
von einer bewegten geschichte zeugen
hier fand eine auseinandersetzung statt
bei der es um sehr viel ging
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
wollte nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
eine entlegene gegend im us bundesstaat
washington
dutzende kilometer von der nächsten
stadt entfernt befindet sich ein ganz
geheimer ort
das gelände ist heute total verlassen
nur karges land ein schrottplatz mit
verrosteten bussen und altmetall
in dieser gegend wohnt kaum jemand es
ist nichts los wer etwas verstecken will
ist hier richtig
da ist ein acker irgendwo im nirgendwo
man sieht diese riesigen betonsockel und
bauten von denen man nicht richtig weiß
was sie da sollen
irgendetwas ist hier komisch riesige
stahltüren führen zu treppen in den
untergrund hier war früher
offensichtlich viel betrieb aber die
anlage hier oben verrät wenig davon was
dort unten ist um das herauszufinden
muss man das ganze näher untersuchen
und das heißt zuerst einmal hinabsteigen
in die tiefe
das ist ein technisch sehr
anspruchsvolle bau und es muss einen
guten grund gegeben haben dass er
unterirdisch und nicht überirdisch
gebaut wurde
da unten ist es stockfinster aber die
verrosteten tunnel die dort unten
verlaufen lassen erahnen dass die anlage
größer sein muss als das was man sehen
kann
wenn man wissen will was das ist braucht
man jemanden der einen taucheranzug
anzieht und reingeht
so war das ganze wasser in den tunnel
möglicherweise auch der grund dafür dass
die anlage aufgegeben wurde
[Musik]
der taucher jim rogers hat über die
jahre viel zeit damit verbracht diesen
faszinierenden ort zu erforschen
wenn man nach anhaltspunkten sucht was
das für eine anlage ist muss man nicht
lange rätseln denn ich stehe gerade
drauf auf einem der wichtigsten hinweise
es gibt zwei sehr große tore von denen
jeder flügel
125 tonnen wiegt bei dieser größe drängt
sich die frage auf wie man die wohl auf
bekommen hat
dieser bau ist eine enorme
ingenieursleistung etwas so groß ist in
dieser verlassenen gegend zu errichten
erfordert viel know how und kapazitäten
und man fragt sich natürlich was zum
teufel hier los war
warum setzt man ein so komplexes bauwerk
mitten in die pampa
die antwort darauf liefert die
geschichte genauer gesagt der kalte
krieg der die usa und die sowjetunion in
den 1950 er jahren an den rand eines
atomkriegs führte
die bedrohung während des kalten kriegs
war real und sehr beängstigend die
latent vorhandene gefahr einer völligen
vernichtung war neu für die usa
die logik von nuklearwaffen ist grauen
erregend es gab die verrückte doktrin
der wechselseitig zugesicherten
zerstörung kurz die nato doktrin demnach
musste man seinen gegner davon
überzeugen dass man bei einem angriff
wenigstens noch zurückschlagen und ihn
im gegenzug auslöschen könnte
die idee vom gleichgewicht des
schreckens bedeutet dass die usa ein
waffenprogramm brauchen um die
sowjetunion abzuschrecken umso mehr da
deren bodentruppen an der europäischen
westgrenze klar in der überzahl sind
ab dem moment als die sowjets über
nuklearwaffen verfügten war abschreckung
von zentraler bedeutung für den westen
da er truppen mäßig stark unterlegen war
die usa entwickeln eine waffe die das
potenzial hat eine ganze nation
auszulöschen die titan
interkontinentalrakete die raketen waren
auf dem neuesten stand der technik
ähnlich wie die der nasa sie hatten eine
reichweite von über 9000 kilometern und
erreichen bis zu 25 facher
schallgeschwindigkeit
doch zurückschlagen kann war wer einen
erstschlag übersteht aus diesem grund
bauen die usa auf der larsen rbs eine
geheime anlage das titan 1 raketensilos
wir sind jetzt ungefähr zwölf meter
unter der erde um eine vorstellung von
den gigantischen ausmaßen dieses
bauwerks zu bekommen muss man hier
herunter gehen und sich die größe dieser
staat röhren und der anderen bauten
ansehen das haut einen echt um
heute steht ein großteil der anlage
unter wasser
wenn man zur abschussvorrichtung kommt
ist da der service aufzug er hängt wegen
des wassers und wegen fehlender wartung
oben an der stelle fest wo die spitze
der rakete war
und von dort beginnt man zu tauchen und
erlebt dann die monstrosität dieser
staat röhren
du guckst nach oben und siehst dass die
125 tonnen tore über die verschlossen
sind
auf dem gelände gibt es insgesamt drei
raketensilos
die drei silos sind durch tunnel
miteinander verbunden wir waren auch
wohnräume ein medizinischer
versorgungsbereich und eine kontroll und
kommandozentrale untergebracht
alles ganz nah bei den raketen um
möglichst schnell einsatz und feuer
bereit zu sein
wir sind jetzt im kontrollraum dem herz
der anlage
die kontrollsysteme in diesem raum
steuerten die betankung mit flüssigem
sauerstoff mit raketentreibstoff das
ausfahren der antennen sowie die ganze
stadt sequenz
dazu die initialisierung des countdowns
die nachdrücken des roten knopf 15
minuten braucht er
die männer im kontrollzentrum hatten
theoretisch die möglichkeit einen
nuklearen holocaust loszutreten
selbst winzige fehler konnten
gigantische konsequenzen haben
hier drin saßen immer leute meist zu
sechst sie waren sehr isoliert bestimmt
sehr einsam aber wahrscheinlich waren
die vier bis sechs man hier drin auch
ein sehr verschworener haufen ein
bisschen wie eine familie aber
gleichzeitig nahmen sie ihren job sehr
ernst weil sie wussten dass jeder
einsatzbefehl ihr letzter sein konnte
die basis war rund um die uhr 365 tage
im jahr in höchster alarmbereitschaft
als eine von hunderten solcher anlagen
verteilt über die usa
parallel zum titan programm hatten die
amerikaner noch andere zum beispiel das
atlas programm dessen entwicklung
parallel lief daran sieht man wie
verzweifelt sie versuchten technologisch
immer die nase vorn zu haben
doch wozu all die mühe die raketen so
tief unter der erde in position zu
bringen
mann stationiert raketen tief unter der
erde und versieht sie mit massiver
panzerung und beton drumrum so dass sie
einen nuklear angriff überstehen würden
es sei denn die raketenbasis bekommt
einen direkten treffer ab wenn sie eine
nukleare angriff aber überstanden hat
dann kann man mit vergeltungs feuer
antworten
das war das kalkül dass genug raketen
einen angriff über stehen würden und wir
dann die silos öffnen und zurück fahren
könnten
doch eine anlage unter die erde zu bauen
bringt auch schwerwiegende probleme mit
sich
es war ein großes problem dass der
grundwasserspiegel an dieser stelle hoch
ist und das wasser permanent
herausgepumpt werden musste so dass die
anlage nicht in mitleidenschaft gezogen
wurde technologisch war das nicht
schwierig aber angesichts der heutigen
wassermengen wird klar wie potenziell
katastrophal das alles hätte enden
können
wasser ist nicht die einzige gefahr für
die silos auch die hunderte von tonnen
an hochentwickelten
treibstoff stellen eine große gefahr dar
die betankung der rakete war sehr
komplex und sehr gefährlich schon der
kleinste fehler konnte fatale folgen
haben
glücklicherweise ist von hier aus wie
eine rakete abgefeuert worden denn die
anlage wurde schon drei jahre nach ihrer
fertigstellung wieder aufgegeben aber
warum die phase der titan raketen
dauerte nicht lange man entwickelte
schon bald bessere raketen die
verlässlicher waren und ohne den
gefährlichen flüssigtreibstoff auskamen
1965 wurde das programm begraben
[Musik]
heute ist die anlage verlassen und
gammelt vor sich hin doch ihre schiere
existenz ist ein mahnmal für die
gefahren die der kalte krieg mit sich
brachte
wenn man zurückblickt dann erscheint es
ziemlich verrückt dass wir milliarden
von dollar für die raketen in diesen
löchern ausgegeben haben während die
sowjets ihre wirtschaft ruinierten um
mithalten zu können und um ihre eigenen
raketen zu bauen aber
auf eine perverse weise hat das ja auch
funktioniert
es gab in dieser phase des kalten
krieges keinen dritten weltkrieg weder
nuklear noch konventionell
[Musik]
südlich von berlin befindet sich ein
ehemaliger prominenten treff und
gleichzeitig ein strategisch wichtiger
punkt für die umsetzung eines tödlichen
plans der fast den lauf der geschichte
verändert hätte
das gelände ist umgeben von ackerland
und feldern man sieht kaputten asphalt
und dann sind da diese riesigen gebäude
der bau erforderte die verwendung aller
modernen materialien aus der ersten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
der ort muss eine besondere bedeutung
gehabt haben der bau hat kaum
strukturelle stützen im innern
die decken sind hoch die mauern dünn
das gebäude wurde entworfen um darin
sehr große dinge zu bauen
doch einiges passt nicht zusammen
was bedeuten die seltsamen schriftzüge
im innern
die wände sind von allerlei graffiti in
den verschiedensten sprachen bedeckt vor
allem russisch da fragt man sich
natürlich warum diese gebäude mitten in
deutschland voller russischer graffiti
sind
[Musik]
die 30er jahre läuten eine neue ära des
technischen fortschritts an die
menschheit will buchstäblich immer höher
hinaus
[Musik]
in die dreißiger jahre sind die goldene
ära der luftfahrt zu
dieser zeit wurden piloten wie
prominente behandelt sie waren
abenteurer der lüfte
da war zum beispiel charles lindbergh
der in der spirit of st louis 1927
erstmals den atlantik überquerte oder
die flüge von amelia earhart und zitate
balbo anfang der 30er jahre immer mehr
europäische und amerikanische flieger
überquerten den atlantik und
vergrößerten die reichweite des lebens
rechtzeitig zu den olympischen
sommerspielen
1936 wird auch der reichssportführer
hafen rangsdorf fertiggestellt an denen
die firma becker flugzeugbau
angegliedert ist
damals ein renommiertes unternehmen das
sich auf den bau von sport und schulungs
flugzeugen spezialisiert hat
rangsdorf ja sehr beliebt unter dem
piloten an der flugschule wurden
bekannte persönlichkeiten ausgebildet
bernd rosemeyer lernt jedes fliegen
diese bach war hier zu gast es war also
ein kommen und gegen gehen von vielen
persönlichkeiten selbst der berühmte
ozean flieger nach lindberg war
rangsdorf
so ist der ort ist nicht weit von berlin
entfernt und anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts war ist das coolste
überhaupt zu lernen wie man ein flugzeug
fliegt viele reiche berliner kamen
hierher und nahmen flugstunden
im zweiten weltkrieg wird der ort zum
fliegerhorst umfunktioniert schon zuvor
hatten die bürger werke für geheime
rüstungsprojekte gearbeitet
durch den versailler vertrag war es den
deutschen untersagt angriffswaffen zu
besitzen sie durften keine schwere
artillerie haben sie durften keine
panzer haben keine u boote keine großen
kriegsschiffe und auch keine flugzeuge
die deutsche regierung ermutigt aber
ihre bürger flugstunden zu nehmen
sie unterstützte unternehmen flugzeuge
zu bauen für die privatleute die fliegen
lernen wollten
es gab einige sport flughäfen sowie in
rangsdorf wo man fliegen lernen konnte
offiziell galt das als sport fliegerei
und hatte angeblich nichts mit dem
militär zu tun aber hier entwickelte
sich der kern der luftwaffe die
kriegswichtige forschung und produktion
in reinsdorf sollte nicht auffallen für
heutige besucher unterscheidet sich der
flugplatz vor allem in einem zentralen
aspekt von modernen flughäfen
im gegensatz zur heutigen zeit wo jeder
airports einer runway besitzt oder
mehreren wie es besitzt die aus beton
gefertigt sind wurde damals noch auf
gras gestartet und gelandet mit über 1
kilometer durchmesser von dem aus die
flugzeuge starteten zur damaligen zeit
waren die motor recht schwach und es
wurde immer gegen den wind gestartet und
die runde formen flugplatzes erlaubte
also immer in jede richtung zu starten
woher der wind auch kamen
als der krieg ausbricht ist das
versteckspiel in rangsdorf vor bei
der wasser und land flughafen für die
zivile luftfahrt wird ein wichtiger teil
der nationalsozialistischen
kriegsmaschinerie
in den großen hangars werden nun
militärmaschinen montiert
wir stehen hier vor dem sonderbau das
war ein gebäude was speziell errichtet
wurde für die kriegsproduktion die
bürger leisten hatte
die flugzeugteile die die deutschen mit
hilfe von kriegsgefangenen auf dem
flugplatz rangsdorf baten waren für
wichtige maschinen im deutschen
waffenarsenal gedacht sowie stocker
bamba oder focke wulf jagd für zeige
wir sind jetzt also innerhalb der
endpunkte halle und hier wurden aus den
ganzen teilen
flugzeuge montiert die flugzeuge stand
damals dicht an dicht rumpf an rumpf die
motoren wurden eingebaut die tragflächen
wurden montiert letztendlich wurden die
flugzeuge eingewogen daher gibt es hier
noch die reste zu sehen von der flugzeug
waage wo der schwerpunkt bestimmt wurde
und dann wurden die großen hallen tore
aufgeschoben und die flugzeuge gingen
hinaus aus dem fels
ironischerweise spielt dieser ort aber
auch eine wichtige rolle bei einem
anderen kriegsentscheidenden projekt den
vielversprechenden umsturzversuch des
militärischen widerstands gegen hitler
in form eines attentats
der flugplatz ist in die geschichte
eingegangen weil der offizier claus von
stauffenberg hier am 20 juli 1944 ein
flugzeug bestieg um zu einem treffen mit
hitler im führerhauptquartier
wolfsschanze zu fliegen in seiner
aktentasche hatte er zwei bomben
oberst von stauffenberg ist einer der
führenden köpfe des militärischen
widerstands gegen den
nationalsozialismus
seitdem die idee der landung der
alliierten in der normandie ist ihm und
seinen mitstreitern klar dass der krieg
verloren ist und nur der tod hitlers und
ein anschließender waffenstillstand
deutschland vor dem vollständigen ruin
bewahren kann schon 1943 formuliert
stauffenberg forderungen an die
alliierten um einen waffenstillstand
auszuhandeln
ob diese jemals zugestimmt hätten ist
fraglich doch ungeachtet dessen wollte
stauffenberg handeln
er verließ die besprechung kurz nach der
ankunft um zur toilette zu gehen stellte
die bombe scharf kam zurück und brachte
sie in position
von stauffenberg verließ hitlers bunker
in rastenburg hört die explosion und
ging davon aus dass hitler tot sei denn
er hat er seine aktentasche direkt neben
hitlers füßen unter dem tisch platziert
doch von stauffenbergs plan geht nicht
auf die
aktentasche mit der bombe darin ist
hinter ein schweres tischbein geschoben
worden so dass die wucht der explosion
von diesem abgefangen wird hitler wird
nur leicht verletzt das attentat schlägt
fehl
schließlich werden stauffenberg und
seine mitverschwörer zusammengetrieben
und hingerichtet einige wurden
erschossen andere gefoltert verhört und
an fleischerhaken aufgehängt ein
qualvoller tod hitler sah sich die
filmaufnahmen dieser exekutionen an
der krieg wütet noch ein knappes jahr
dann übernehmen neue herren in rangsdorf
das zepter
der platz wurde ende april aufgegeben
als 42 und am nächsten tag schon war die
russische armee die rote armee hier bei
einer abend diesem platz und flogen von
hier aus auch angriffe auf berlin
die sowjets waren groß darin
infrastrukturen zu übernehmen und
umzuwidmen
sie nahmen die fertigungsstätten in
besitz um dort motoren und speziell
düsentriebwerke herzustellen sie bauten
hubschrauberlandeplätze so dass sie den
flugplatz für helikopter einsätze nutzen
konnten und besetzten ihn für viele
jahrzehnte
nach der deutschen wiedervereinigung
ziehen die sowjets aus rangsdorf ab und
überlassen die anlage ihrem schicksal
[Musik]
heute ist der flugplatz langsdorf
verlassen und verfällt obwohl er unter
denkmalschutz steht aber seinen platz in
der geschichte ist ihnen sicher
es gibt so viele nazi städten die nur
finsternis böses und verzweiflung
ausstrahlen
und dann ist da dieser flugplatz der
etwas ganz besonderes darstellt
es ist tröstlich dass es da einen
kleinen kreis von leuten gab die den mut
hatten ihr leben aufs spiel zu setzen um
der dunkelheit ein ende zu setzen
in einer abgelegenen ecke des
us-bundesstaates colorado gibt es eine
außergewöhnliche landschaft die
jahrzehntelang verlassen und vergessen
war
topografisch betrachtet ist dieser
flecken erde wirklich außergewöhnlich
steil abfallende canyons und täler und
überall tafelberge es ist ein fest für
die augen
das wüsten plateau im südwesten
colorados ist eine wunderbare landschaft
überall klippen versteckte und
geheimnisvolle ecken man könnte dort
lange untertauchen ohne dass einen
jemand finden würde
und offenbar hat jemand genau das getan
denn versteckt zwischen den felsen
finden sich faszinierende behausungen
das einzigartige an diesem ort ist dass
man leicht daran vorbeiläuft wenn man
nicht gerade nach oben schaut
das ganze gebiet atmet geschichte auch
wenn man das auf den ersten blick nicht
sieht
man kann viele tage und wochen das tal
auf und ab wandern ohne diese dörfer
wahrzunehmen
und das obwohl die ruine nicht versteckt
oder verstreut sind
sie sind überall
ruhig so weiter sorgerecht das sind
nicht nur ein paar kleine siedlungen das
ist eher eine art statt in den felsen
denn sie sind wirklich faszinierend
nicht nur wegen ihrer lage hoch oben in
den felsen sondern auch wegen ihrer
schieren größe
oder überall sind diese kleinen felsen
wohnungen in die klippen gehauen
teilweise sind sie schwer zu erkennen
weit weg vom boden wahnsinnig abgelegen
und unzugänglich
doch warum sind sie da
wovor fürchteten sich jene die sie
einstmals gebaut haben
[Musik]
im späten neunzehnten jahrhundert machen
zwei cowboys auf der suche nach ihren
rindern eine erstaunliche entdeckung ich
werde ihnen gleich etwas unglaubliches
zeigen aber erst müssen wir diese leiter
rauf
christy brown ist fremdenführerin seit
15 jahren erforscht sie die ruinen und
die geschichte ihrer erbauer
wir sind gerade diese leiter hier zehn
meter hoch geklettert und befinden uns
hunderte meter über dem boden des
canyons jetzt gehen wir ins berke
niehaus
die männer die diese anlage gefunden
haben sind rein zufällig darauf gestoßen
die entdeckung dieses ortes wird den
levels zugeschrieben das war eine
familie von viehzüchtern aus mengkofen
fiel irgendwann auf dass die dunklen
umrisse die sahen fels behausungen waren
stellen sie sich das mal vor da klettern
sie hinauf laufen durch diese alten
behausungen und realisieren dass sie
wahrscheinlich der erste sind der hier
seinen fuß rein gesetzt hat seit die
ursprünglichen bewohner diesen ort
verlassen haben
tatsächlich haben die cowboys durch
zufall eine der bedeutendsten
archäologischen stätten nordamerikas
gefunden mesa verde
[Musik]
nach der entdeckung konnten sich die
archäologen dort so richtig austoben es
gab so viel zu entdecken und je länger
sie gruben desto mehr fanden sehen
neugierde liegt in der natur des
menschen
er will immer mehr wissen und genau so
ging es den archäologen je mehr sie
herausfanden desto mehr fragen stellten
sie
[Musik]
hinweise darüber wie alt die siedlungen
sind und wer sie erbaut hat befinden
sich in den bauten selbst
[Musik]
wenn man sich die öffnungen anschaut
könnte man meinen dass das fenster sind
da sie sehr klein sind aber in
wirklichkeit sind dass türen was
rückschlüsse über die größe dieser leute
zulässt und wenn man dann in der
geschichte zurückgeht kann man ungefähr
1 grenzen wann die leute in diesem
gebiet hier gelebt haben könnten
[Musik]
die untersuchungen der archäologen
ergaben dass die fans behausungen von
amerikanischen ureinwohnern stammen von
denen wir bis dahin nichts wussten
diese kultur ist älter als die der
stämme und völker die bei der ankunft
der europäer hier lebten
[Musik]
die archäologen fanden heraus dass die
felsbrocken von einer bevölkerungsgruppe
namens anna sie stammen
forscher sind sich uneins wann sich die
anna sah sie als eigenständige kultur
entwickelten
doch neueste forschungen gehen vom
zwölften jahrhundert nach christus aus
in jedem fall waren sie offensichtlich
bemerkenswerte leute
diana sie müssen sehr geschickt gewesen
sein sie waren korbmacher und töpfer und
stellten viele gegenstände des täglichen
gebrauchs her
nicht zuletzt haben sie diesen
erstaunlichen ort hier gebaut
eine der wichtigsten entdeckungen war
dass die 800 jahre alten fels
behausungen nur teil eines größeren
ganzen sind
[Musik]
sie waren nur ein kleines teil in einem
riesigen puzzle
die archäologen haben insgesamt 4.700
städten auf einer fläche von 10.000
quadratkilometern entdeckt die von
dieser bevölkerungsgruppe erbaut und für
viele jahre mit großem erfolg bewohnt
wurden
die fällt siedlungen waren
offensichtlich nicht ihr ursprüngliches
zu hause
obwohl die felsen wohnungen zu den
ersten siedlungen gehörten die entdeckt
wurden fanden die archäologen heraus
dass die geschichte dieser kultur viel
weiter zurückreicht was wir hier sehen
ist eine wohnstätte in der sie lebten
bevor sie in die felsen zogen diese
grubenhäuser erlaubten es den leuten
näher an ihren äckern zu leben und
gleichzeitig boten sie schutz für die
wachsende bevölkerung
zu hoch zeiten lebten geschätzte 30.000
anastasi auf den hügeln der messe sie
bauten strassen und sonnentempel legten
wasserreservoire an und betrieben
ackerbau
die anastasi herrschten auf einer fläche
von 100.000 quadratkilometer
damit zählen sie sicherlich zu den
wichtigsten zivilisationen amerikas uns
in zweifelsohne sehr bedeutend
genau genommen haben sie eine art reich
errichtet
doch dann muss etwas einschneidendes
passiert sein denn diana sie verließen
die tafel ebene und siedelten um in die
felsen
und man fragt sich warum eine kultur die
sich so gut auf den tafelbergen
eingerichtet hatte in diese fels
behausungen umzog und
mysteriöser weise blieben sie hier auch
nur für kurze zeit
was auch immer sie dazu brachte ihre
dörfer und höfe auf den messias zu
verlassen um in dieser abgelegenen und
gefährlichen fels behausungen zu ziehen
sie müssen einen triftigen grund gehabt
haben
waren es ökologische gründe oder ging es
dabei um sicherheit
vielleicht führten sie krieg gegen
andere stimme es gibt viele theorien und
wir wissen es immer noch nicht ganz
genau
irgendetwas muss so furchtbar gewesen
sein dass sie das risiko auf sich nahmen
mit ihren familien und kleinkindern in
dieser hohen nicht ungefährlichen felsen
und diese engen räume zu ziehen doch
wofür auch immer sie geflohen sind es
muss sich gelohnt haben am ende
verschwinden diana sie komplett aber
warum
es gibt keine sprache und keine
schriftlichen zeugnisse die den
archäologischen funden zugeordnet werden
können
daher können wir die dimensionen dieser
zivilisation nicht im vollen maße
verstehen und werden wohl auch nie
wissen warum sie unterging
seit jahrzehnten suchen archäologen nach
einer erklärung für den untergang dieser
großen zivilisation
offenbar waren die feld siedlungen nur
etwa 100 jahre lang bewohnt dann muss
ein brutales ereignis diese periode
beendet haben wie archäologische funde
nahe liegen
man fand menschliche überreste die
hinweise auf einen gewaltsamen tod
aufwiesen daher geht man davon aus dass
es einen massiven konflikt gab ob nun
intern oder extern
da kann man nur spekulieren
es gibt eine menge theorien darüber
warum diese menschen verschwunden sind
zb konflikte mit anderen
bevölkerungsgruppen gesellschaftliche
veränderungen dürre oder klimawandel
letztlich haben wir keine klare antwort
auf die frage nach dem warum
[Applaus]
was auch immer der grund für das
verschwinden war die ruinen der
ehemaligen bewohner stehen noch und
hüten ihr geheimnis bis heute
wenn man sich diese wunderschönen fels
behausungen ansieht all die arbeit und
die ingenieursleistungen die da rein
gesteckt wurde und wenn man sich dann
klar macht dass sie nur einen herzschlag
vielleicht zwei drei generationen lang
bewohnt waren das ist schon tragisch
im karibik paradies und lucia stehen
ruinen die an eine dunkle vergangenheit
der insel erinnern
das ist ein tropisches paradies mit
herrlichen stränden und dann sieht man
diese verfallenen europäischen gebäude
ein gebäude sieht so aus als ob es aus
dem späten neunzehnten jahrhundert
stammt es wurde sicher auf
unterschiedlichste art und weise genutzt
es war lange zeit im einsatz und wurde
aufwendig instand gehalten aber jetzt
ist es dem verfall preisgegeben
doch warum wurden diese gebäude einst
auf der entlegenen tropeninsel gebaut
[Musik]
dieser ort ist von sehr großer bedeutung
und war einmal das zentrum einer
auseinandersetzung bei der es um sehr
viel ging
es ist nur schwer vorstellbar dass diese
idyllische gegend schauplatz von so viel
gewalt und konflikten war
wie kam es dass sind loser zu einer
derart umkämpften insel wurde
[Musik]
die karibik hat fruchtbare böden und ein
warmes klima ein perfekter ort um
zuckerrohr anzubauen und zuckerwaren gut
dass im 18 jahrhundert in europa sehr
gefragt war
zucker inseln in der karibik bedeuteten
viel geld für die kolonialherren
deswegen waren alle europäischen länder
so versessen darauf ein oder zwei
zuckerinsel zu besitzen
doch die insel kann noch mit einem
weiteren punkt buchen dem hafen von
castries
der tiefwasserhafen war der eigentliche
trumpf er hatte eine immense
strategische bedeutung
frankreich und großbritannien die
supermächte jener zeit kämpfen immer
wieder um das eiland
schon während der ersten hälfte des 17
jahrhunderts versuchen beide die insel
zu kolonialisieren
im jahr
1674 wird die insel dann französische
kolonie erworben für die französische
westindien kompanie
1778 gut 100 jahre später kommt es zu
einer seeschlacht zwischen briten und
franzosen bei der die briten
triumphieren aber auch der nacht oben
kämpfe auf der insel die erst anfang des
19 jahrhunderts britische kolonie wird
diese verfallenen gemäuer zeugen von den
auseinandersetzungen
dr greig williams ist ein spezialist für
jene ära von saint lucia
wir gehen jetzt zur half moon batterie
sie wurde von den franzosen errichtet
als diese begannen st lucia stärker zu
befestigen
jede fassung war mit einer 20 zentimeter
kann ohne ausgestattet mit diesen
geschützten wurde die hafeneinfahrt vor
den britischen schiffen verteidigt die
hier rein wollten
siebenmal franzosen siebenmal briten die
kontrolle über die insel wechselte
sieben mal zwischen den verfeindeten
großmächten frankreich und
großbritannien hin und her
auf jahrhunderte langes blutvergießen
folgt anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zunehmende eigenständigkeit
die festungen werden sich selbst
überlassen bis zum ausbruch des zweiten
weltkriegs 1939
[Musik]
als der krieg begann standen die gebäude
leer also besetzten die briten sie und
brachten hier während des zweiten
weltkriegs ihre soldaten unter
im laufe des zweiten weltkriegs
entwickelte sich die karibik zu einer
wichtigen front
denn die alliierten in europa die rote
armee die briten die us-truppen sie alle
wurden mit öl aus den usa versorgt mit
tankern die durch den golf von mexiko
und die karibik bis nach europa führen
die deutsche kriegsmarine wittert ihre
chance den kriegswichtigen nachschub zu
kappen
die deutschen setzten auf effektive
waffen wie kleine kriegsschiffe und u
boote
sie wollten so viele amerikanische
handelsschiffe mit kurs auf
großbritannien vernichten wie irgend
möglich
die größte bedrohung für die
handelsschiffe geht von den deutschen
boden aus
es war ein katz-und-maus-spiel die
alliierten jagten die deutschen u-boote
die versuchten sich im meeres armen und
in buchten zu verstecken um dort neue
vorräte zu laden und um nicht von den
zerstörern entdeckt zu werden
jeder hafen in nordamerika und in der
karibik war voll mit leuten die nach
paris copen auf dem meer ausschau
hielten
neue anlagen werden gebaut und alte
verstärkt um der deutschen kriegsmarine
zu trotzen
das hier ist meadows batterie erst war
hier eine französische festung dann kam
die briten und während des zweiten
weltkriegs bauten sie sie im kampf gegen
die deutschen aus
diese bauten zeugen auch von den
unglaublichen dimensionen des zweiten
weltkriegs der jede noch so entfernte
ecke auf dem erdball erreicht hat
am 9 märz 1942 ist die festung erneut
schauplatz von kampfhandlungen
der junge michael köster ist dabei
vor mitternacht hörten wir eine laute
explosion
wir waren sofort wach und ging auf die
veranda
da seien die leute die sagten dass sie
angegriffen wurden
es war ein heilloses durcheinander
[Musik]
die medal battery feiert in die dunklen
gewässer doch da ist es bereits zu spät
ein u boot hat es in den tiefwasserhafen
von castries geschafft und verheerende
zerstörungen angerichtet
das deutsche u-boot
161 ist heimlich in den hafen gefahren
hat seine torpedos abgefeuert und zwei
große britische frachter versenkt einen
8000 und einen 5000 tonnen frachter
beide seiten und haben viele menschen in
den tod gerissen
die deutschen u boote kamen hier hinein
sie waren sehr schnell der hafen ist
nicht groß sie wussten dass wir schlecht
vorbereitet waren
ein polizist osten looser der hafen
wache auf dieser alten festung hatte
nahm das u-boot mit einem
maschinengewehr ins visier und feuerte
bis es den hafen verlassen hatte
das deutsche u-boot ist glücklicherweise
der letzte angreifer der karibikinsel
nach dem krieg werden die militärischen
worten die in castries lange eine
dominante rolle spielten aufgegeben
noch heute thronen sie still über der
insel und erinnern an die turbulente
vergangenheit des eilands
wer heute nach castries kommt kann sich
die schiffsschraube von einem der
versenkten frachter ansehen sie erinnert
daran dass dies ein ort war der für die
großmächte einst ökonomisch und
strategisch von großer bedeutung war
der zweite weltkrieg ist nicht nur eine
geschichte von großen nationen und
bedeutenden schlachten
selbst in diesen kleinen insel hafen hat
er sich geschlichen
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnungen stille zeugen
von erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang